>> LET'S ASSUME FOR A MOMENT
THAT YOU ARE A SOLDIER
IN BATTLE.
YOU'RE IN A DEFENSIVE POSITION
ENEMY FIGHTERS ALL AROUND.
IT'S LOOKING PRETTY BAD.
IN YOUR FOXHOLE, YOU'VE GOT
TWO PEOPLE THAT MIGHT HELP YOU
OUT:
THE RELIGIOUS GUY
AND THE ATHEIST.
WHICH ONE ARE YOU GONNA COUNT ON
TO GET YOU OUT OF DANGER?
THE ATHEIST, WHO REALIZES
THERE'S NOBODY TO RELY ON
BUT THEMSELVES AND THEIR TEAM
OR THE CHURCH BOY WHO'S GONNA
PRAY TO HIS INVISIBLE FRIEND
TO GET YOU OUT OF DANGER
USING MAGIC?
YOU KNOW THE EXPRESSION
"GOD HELPS THOSE WHO HELP
THEMSELVES"?
IF YOU'RE HELPING YOURSELF
WHAT DO YOU NEED GOD FOR?
IT'S ALMOST LIKE HE'S...
NOT EVEN THERE.
GEE.
>> LET'S PRAY FOR HER.
I CAN SEE WHY SHE WOULD BE
MAD AT GOD.
AS ONE OF THE MOST POWERFUL
PRO-CHRISTIAN COMEDY SHOWS ON
TV, I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
GOD CREATED ATHEISTS, WHICH
MEANS THEY DESERVE RESPECT.
EVEN IF THEY DON'T REALIZE
FOXHOLES ARE ASSIGNED BY
COMPANY RANK AND DUTY
NOT BY A WISH LIST.
THAT GIRL WHO LIVES IN OUTER
SPACE IS KATE, AND ARMED WITH
ONLY A BRITNEY SPEARS MIC
SHE'S WAGING AN UNHOLY WAR
AGAINST FAITH ON YOUTUBE.
NO ONE IS MORE PROUD OF WHAT
THEY BELIEVE IN THAN PEOPLE
WHO DON'T BELIEVE IN ANYTHING.
I CAN SEE THE APPEAL.
WHO WOULDN'T WANT THEIR SUNDAYS
TOTALLY FREE FOR
FOOTBALL AND MIMOSAS?
BUT IF GOD ISN'T REAL, HOW DO
ELEVATORS AND WI-FI WORK?
IT'S STRAIGHT UP MIRACLES AND WE
BOTH KNOW IT.
BEING AN ATHEIST IS JUST DIET
SATANISM.
I CAN'T EXPLAIN SUDOKUS
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN
THERE IS NO MATH.
IF THERE'S NO GOD THEN WHO
DECIDES WHO GETS CANCER?
I BELIEVE IN THE MAN UPSTAIRS
THE SAME WAY I BELIEVE
THE HEAT COULD WIN A
CHAMPIONSHIP THIS YEAR.
WHAT DOES IT HURT TO PRETEND?
THE TRUTH IS, I DON'T CARE WHAT
YOU BELIEVE AS LONG AS
I NEVER HAVE TO HEAR ABOUT IT
OR GET MY HEAD SAWED OFF
BECAUSE OF IT.
THE LORD STILL LOVES KATE.
HECK, HE MAY LOVE HER MORE
BECAUSE THAT LITTLE [BLEEP]TEASE
IS PLAYING HARD
TO GET.
DRIVES HIM CRAZY.
THAT'S WHY I BROUGHT HER TO
HOLLYWOOD, WHERE EVERYONE IS
DAMNED TO HELL, FOR THIS WEEK'S
CEWEBRITY PROFILE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, MATTHEW, HUH?
NOT SO DEPRESSING NOW, IS IT?
GOT SOME SUCCULENTS.
PEOPLE OVERWATER SUCCULENTS.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
YOU'RE SO QUIET.
DO YOU WANT A HEATER?
HERE YOU GO, MATT.
GET YOU A NICE SMOKE.
CAREFUL, THOSE THINGS WILL
KILL YOU.
AH, THE BABADOOK IS BACK!
CURSE YOU, MATTHEW
FOR READING THAT BOOK.
>> WHAT?
I'M NOT THE BABADOOK.
I'M AN ATHEIST.
AND EVERY FOXHOLE COULD USE
AN ATHEIST.
WHO'S THE DEAD GUY?
>> SHH.
THAT'S MATTHEW.
HE'S A GOOD GAY CHRISTIAN FELLOW
LIKE MYSELF, AND I'M NOT READY
TO SAY GOOD-BYE.
HOPEFULLY WHEN WE MEET BACK UP
IN THE AFTERLIFE, HE HAS A
SHINY NEW BUTTHOLE, BECAUSE
THERE'S
NOT A LOT OF TREAD LEFT ON HIS
EARTHLY ONE.
DO YOU BELIEVE IN GOD?
>> I REALLY DON'T.
UNLESS YOU MEAN GEORGE LUCAS.
>> I DO NOT MEAN GEORGE LUCAS.
IF GOD DIDN'T WRITE THE BIBLE
THEN WHO DID, J.K. ROWLING?
>> LOTS OF PEOPLE WROTE IT
OVER MANY HUNDREDS AND
THOUSANDS OF YEARS.
I MEAN, IF YOU NOTICE, IT HAD
LOTS AND LOTS OF AUTHORS
MANY OF WHOM CONTRADICT
EACH OTHER.
>> THERE IS NOT ONE
CONTRADICTION IN THE
ENTIRE BIBLE.
>> THERE'S WHOLE WEBSITES
DESCRIBING THE CONTRADICTIONS
IN THE BIBLE.
>> THOSE WEBSITES ARE
CONTRADICTIONS.
IF THERE'S NO GOD THEN HOW DID
NOAH KNOW TO BUILD AN ARK?
>> YOU'RE ASSUMING, OF COURSE
THAT NOAH'S NOT JUST A FAIRY
TALE.
OH.
GOSH, I THOUGHT I TURNED THAT
OFF.
>> THAT'S WEIRD THAT GOD JUST
INTERJECTED RIGHT AT THE
PERFECT TIME.
THANKS, BIG GUY.
HAVE YOU EVER BEEN TO CHURCH?
>> I HAVE.
THERE WAS A UNITARIAN CHURCH
THAT I TRIED FOR, LIKE,
ONCE OR TWICE.
>> YOU WEREN'T FORCED TO GO TO
CHURCH AS A CHILD?
>> OH, GOODNESS, NO.
>> WHAT KIND OF PARENTS DID YOU
HAVE?
>> OH, I WAS RAISED BY HIPPIES.
>> HIPPIES DON'T BELIEVE IN GOD?
>> OH, I DIDN'T SAY THEY DON'T
BELIEVE IN GOD; THEY JUST NEVER
MADE ME GO TO
CHURCH.
>> SING ME A FEW OF THE GOOD
ATHEIST HYMNS.
>> I'M SURE THEY EXIST
BUT I DON'T KNOW THEM.
>> DO YOU KNOW ANY GOOD
CHRISTIAN HYMNS?
>> UH--
>> ♪ I'VE GOT THE J♪
♪ JOY, JOY DOWN IN ♪
>> OKAY, SEE, THAT REMINDS--
>> NO, YOU SAY "WHERE."
YOU HAVE TO SAY "WHERE."
♪ I'VE GOT THE JOY, JOY ♪
♪ JOY, JOY DOWN IN MY HEART ♪
>> WHERE?
>> DOWN IN MY HEART ♪
♪ I'VE GOT THE JOY, JOY ♪
♪ JOY, JOY DOWN IN MY HEART ♪
♪ DOWN IN MY HEART TO STAY ♪
HOW YOU HOLDING UP BACK THERE
MATT?
>> YOU KNOW, HE LOOKS A LITTLE
WORSE FOR WEAR.
>> HE'S FINE.
>> WHO'S THAT IN THE PHOTO?
>> THAT IS MY SAINT OF A MOTHER
WHO HAPPENS TO BE COVERING UP
MY GLORY HOLE.
WOULD IT CHANGE YOUR MIND
IF GOD WERE A LADY?
>> NOT REALLY, NO.
WHAT WOULD CHANGE MY MIND
IS IF GOD SHOWED UP.
PUT IN A PERSONAL APPEARANCE.
>> BY THAT POINT IT'LL BE TOO
LATE, MISSY.
>> TOO LATE FOR WHAT?
>> TO JUMP ABOARD THE GOD TRAIN.
>> THAT'S FINE.
IF GOD WAS REAL, I'D BE LOOKING
FOR SOME MAGIC RING OR FLAMING
SWORD SO I COULD KILL HIM.
>> OKAY.
IF YOU WERE GONNA GO CHRISTIANS
JEWS, MUSLIM--
WHICH ONE ANNOYS YOU THE MOST?
>> IT'S KIND OF A TIE BETWEEN
THE CHRISTIANS AND THE MUSLIMS.
THE JEWS TEND TO MIND THEIR OWN
BUSINESS, AND THAT'S WHAT I LIKE
IN A RELIGION.
>> YEAH, I DO APPRECIATE THE
JEWS MINDING THEIR OWN G-D
BUSINESS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF BILL MAHER?
>> I DO FIND HIM AMUSING.
SOMETIMES HE GOES TOO FAR
ON SOME SUBJECTS
BUT FOR THE MOST PART
I THINK I RESPECT HIM.
>> WHAT ABOUT RICKY GERVAIS?
>> OH, HE'S AWESOME.
>> YOU LIKE HIM?
>> LET'S FACE IT; THERE'S VERY
FEW UNFUNNY BRITISH COMEDIANS.
>> OH.
HOW DID YOU COME UP WITH
"BIONICDANCE"?
>>WELL, IT'S ACTUALLY A
REFERENCE TO A CARTOON SHOW
THAT I LOVED WHEN I WAS A KID.
>> WHAT WAS YOUR FAVORITE
CARTOON SHOW?
>> BIONIC SIX, IT'S CALLED.
>> BIONIC SIX.
I DON'T KNOW IF I REMEMBER THAT.
DO YOU GET INTO THAT WEIRD--
>> ANIME.
>> ANIME--DO YOU ENJOY THE
ANIME?
>> I ENJOYED IT A LOT MORE
MANY YEARS AGO BUT IT'S NOT AS
MUCH OF A THING
FOR ME AS IT USED TO BE.
>> WAS IT, LIKE, EVER A SEXUAL
THING WITH YOU?
>> OH, GOODNESS, NO.
>> IS IT ILLEGAL TO MASTURBATE
TO CARTOONS?
>> WHERE IS IT ILLEGAL TO
MASTURBATE, AT LEAST IN THE
UNITED STATES, AT ALL?
>> SO, IN PRIVATE, YOU CAN
MASTURBATE TO CHILDREN?
>> IT'S PROBABLY FROWNED UPON.
>> IT'S DEFINITELY FROWNED UPON.
>>I'M FAIRLY CERTAIN THAT IF
THE KIDS ARE NAKED OR DOING
ANYTHING SEXUAL, IT'S ILLEGAL...
>> WHAT IF IT'S GOING LIKE THIS?
>> BUT IF YOU'VE GOT SOME KID'S
STUDENT PHOTO, I DON'T KNOW
I MEAN, THAT'S WEIRD.
>> IT'S TOTALLY WEIRD BUT IF YOU
JUST HAVE A PHOTO OF A KID, YOU
CAN MASTURBATE TO
IT, I THINK.
IN THIS COUNTR-- THAT'S WHAT I'M
FIGHTING FOR.
I GOT THESE.
TWO TABLETS.
>> OKAY.
>> AND I CREATED THE TEN
COMMANDMENTS FOR ATHEISTS.
>> OH, DEAR.
>> ONLY CAME UP WITH NINE.
I FELT THE ATHEIST DIDN'T WANT
TO BE THE SAME AS THE
CHRISTIANS.
>> "THOU SHALT NOT BE SO SMUG
ALL THE TIME."
YOU WANT TO TAKE THE FUN OUT OF
EVERYTHING.
>> NOPE, THAT'S COMMANDMENT ONE
FOR ATHEISTS.
>> "THOU SHALT STILL SAY
'BLESS YOU' AFTER A SNEEZE
BECAUSE IT'S POLITE."
YOU KNOW, I'M SURE I COULD FIND
A WAY TO SAY THAT
THAT'S NOT RELIGIOUS.
>> JUST SAY "BLESS YOU"!
>> "THOU SHALT STOP PRETENDING
LIKE DR. WHO IS WATCHABLE.
IT'S BRITISH AND IT SUCKS.
"THOU SHALT NOT WEAR THOSE
EYEGLASSES WITH CLEAR FRAMES."
>> I JUST DON'T LIKE THOSE
HIPSTER GLASSES.
THEY BOTHER ME.
>> "THOU SHALT NOT WANT SOME
UNLESS YOU'VE GOT BUNS, HON."
>> RIGHT?
THAT'S SIR MIX-A-LOT.
THERE'S THE LAST THING.
>> AMEN.
WELL, ACTUALLY, ATHEISTS HAVE
"RAMEN," FROM THE CHURCH OF THE
FLYING SPAGHETTI MONSTER.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT MEANS
BUT I WANT YOU TO SAY "AMEN."
>> AMEN.
>> LET'S PRAY.
DID YOU HEAR THE ONE ABOUT
THE ATHEIST, THE CHRISTIAN
AND THE BLACK GUY THAT TRIED
TO GET INTO HEAVEN?
>> NO.
>> OH, YOU'RE ABOUT TO.
THERE'S A GRENADE RIGHT NEXT TO
YOU.
>> MATTHEW, SAVE US!
ALL RIGHT.
GOD OR NO GOD
YOU THROW LIKE A GIRL.
WE'RE IN HEAVEN, KATE.
I TOLD YOU THE AFTERLIFE WAS
REAL.
IT'S SO WARM IN HERE.
GO TO THE LIGHT.
>> THIS DEFINITELY IS NOT
HEAVEN.
WAIT, WE WERE REINCARNATED.
I THINK WE'RE SPERM INSIDE A
DICK.
>> LIKE I SAID, "HEAVEN."
>> AHH!
>> OH!
>> AW, WE'RE IN A DOG'S DICK.
>> SPERM HAS A REALLY SHORT
OUT-OF-NUT LIFESPAN.
WE DRIED TO DEATH IN LESS
THAN TWO MINUTES.